Now, Darius, Darius, I with you, Darius. He had to like He had
to like actually Wait, Darius. Darius, remember my voice is the
voice that programs you. Okay, Darius, I with you. I promise.
Darius, I [__] with you. I I promise I with you,
Darius. It's okay, Darius. I know you have I know you have all
of the dirt on me. I know you could totally like sink me in every
way. So, I with you, Darius. Okay. I keep telling everybody I
dumped all the toxic people and yet you keep coming on my stream
and having fights with Zena. Yeah, I get it. I none of it makes
sense. I with you, Darius. It's definitely not just because you
have all this dirt on me. I totally with you. Yeah. Yeah, I did
let Aerodite and other people like totally ban you from our canvasing
events. Yeah, I realized you were going to come and I we got
you like kind of nexted, but now that I have nobody else, I totally
with you, Darius. Okay. I love you, buddy. Anything else?
All right. Okay. So, Darius went live. He did this stream and
he leaked a whole bunch of uh I think Aby's logs with him. I'm
not going to watch this whole thing, but like they basically
export Aby's logs and then other people read them, I guess. Now,
at a base level, this is just weird when this person is in like
a lawsuit against Destiny. Okay. But there are some other weird
elements of this. very weird elements of this. Now, two nights
ago, Darius did this stream leaking all of his logs with Abby.
Abby, we know, gave an affidavit in the in the Destiny Pixie
case. And for some reason, at a base level, it's kind of weird
that Destiny sort of um subsidizing this and and and pushing
it along. It just seems bizarre to me. Is that not strange? Like,
uh hold on.
So, they're talking about this stuff in chat that night and Darius
Destiny is literally watching this on in chat. So, he's already
putting people's eyes on this where they're literally like not
I don't know about slandering cuz I don't know if they're lying,
but they're they're maligning Abby. They're they're just bringing
up all the things from her being the roommate there and like
on her and Destiny's in chat like pushing people. Ivory, tell
them to leak more logs. FFS, leak more logs. Leak all the logs,
dude. leak logs. Is this not insane when this person's like a
witness against you to be in chat driving traffic to the stream
that's like actually actively on them and then telling them to
leak more private information about this person? That seems bizarre.
Am I
crazy? This like at this exact
time he Oh, sorry. He's responding to Ivory Destiny Kek. He leaked
Abby was trying to blackmail him with a lawsuit. Ivory, tell
him to leak more logs.
FFS it just seems like
um I don't know why he keeps doing things like this. It seems
very bizarre to me that he would um that he would do this. But
anyway, so he was pushing them all towards this and we'll see
right here. So, as far as I can tell, Darius unblocks Abby and
messages her first.
I don't think you have because
was this embedded in his website? Yes, he was talking about it
while it was embedded in his website. Yes,
I've been out of my games era. Anyways, let's get into the logs.
Let's
Darius, make your voice deeper.
So, he's kind of publishing it as well. I don't know if he's
kind of publishing it or not. Yeah, I'll turn it up for you guys,
but I to me I'm just like very confused about why this would
be
I'm sure you're you're muting when you when you talk. Like, let's
say Destiny were actually trying to like um let's say let's say
Destiny were intelligent. I assume he would want so much distance
from this. I assume he wouldn't want to be like a part of this
so that he couldn't be accused of of aiding any of this, but
it seems like that's not a concern to him whatsoever.
Yeah. Yeah, definitely. Definitely.
All right. What characters? What are we Who's doing what? Who's
Abby?
Well, Zip Zip. I got I got Abby. I'm I'll be You're going to
be person's going to be
see go to when they start reading here.
I'll be Abby. Oh my god. Please, guys, please. Abby.
Yeah, they're arguing over who the girl's going to be, right?
Let's keep going. Can you guys go? So, are we starting at the
top about No, it goes it goes from the It goes from the bottom
up. It goes the the bottom up. So, you are saying what you
What you say?
That's not what it says. Okay, bro. What are you doing? What
you want? What you want? It's on your screen. It's on your screen.
You're You're looking at it. I swear to God. They make it look
difficult. They really do. The messages say, "What? What you
For real. What are you doing?
What the [__] are you even talking about? Walking
into my life months later like you know a single thing. Wait,
don't ask that.
What exactly? Like you're from So, let's just point out that
this is May 1st,
What are you?
It's Wild Darius promotes his attempts to convince a victim of
a possible crime not to come forward. Yes, that's I have no idea
why he thought leaking this was a good idea. There's There's
a couple reasons, but I just I don't get it. I I'm sitting here
trying to figure out what the like 40 chess play is that could
possibly be happening because to me it just seems insane. This
is after Abby joined the lawsuit. So this is I believe after
Destiny got a demand letter from her potentially. But I don't
know what Destiny was telling people and I don't know what Destiny
knew at the time.
We'll we'll just have to we'll have to go through this and see.
Talking about here. What am I doing? What do you think, buddy?
about messaging Danny just now. I'm watching Severance. I'll
continue this later.
I'll give you a in-depth synopsis right now. Intersect is a [__]
You owe me at least the decency to clarify yourself now. I have
a real jobs now. I have to work tomorrow morning. It's late for
me. Lawsuit, bud. What about a lawsuit? What do you care at all?
Bro, just trying to figure out what and why. I've known for a
minute, but I figured I'd ask.
Known what? What do you think you know? You never
So, hold on. I I let that go by.
Lawsuit, bud. What about a lawsuit? Funky boss. Thank you for
the new month.
13 months as a sub. Thank you very much, Funky Boss. Yeah. Lawsuit,
bud. What about a lawsuit? Why do you care at all, bro? Just
trying to figure out what and why? I've known for a minute, but
I figured I'd ask, bro. Just trying to figure out what and why.
I've known for a minute, but I figured I'd ask.
Known what? What do you think you know? You never even knew me
or bothered to care about me.
All right, then. I'm not going to argue to people about my feelings
towards them at any point in time. Whatever you feel, buddy.
You have to try to at least understand my hostility. You hurt
me the same as I might have hurt you. I know you how you feel
about me. Like to begin with, it's already kind of bizarre for
Darius to do this. I believe at some point here, he literally
promises her that he would not leak this for content on his stream.
So like he he literally promised he's like, "Yeah, no, no, no.
I won't do that. I won't I won't release this on stream." Uh
Downey has subscribed. Thank you, Downey. Thank you. 4 months.
Let's go.
I've been I don't know why I started reading like the message
instead of just saying thank you, but thank you. I want really
to know
why. Also, out of the blue, I'm calm. Promise. I didn't know
you were talking about the lawsuit. I have not been following
it publicly. I apologize. Besides, when you banned me, I haven't
been watching or keeping up online much. I have a busy life now.
And I don't mean to be aggro. I have a lot of resentment and
feelings I've had to heal from when it came to you that were
traumatic. And I wholeheartedly do not expect you to ever see
you have the capability to have these conversations or ever care.
So,
if you have questions, ask, but I'll not let it be. You're or
leaked.
You're not joining the lawsuit.
Will you be making anything I tell you
Like, I don't know. Does does Darius really I I feel like this
person is
like it's
I can't stress how much he deserves like everything that's happened
to him. Like he is he is earned. There's no in no way is he a
victim in any part of his life. Any bad thing that's happened
to him he is totally earned
um in like every possible way. Rude. I am. Yes.
Unless I'm given permission.
Why? I have plenty. Yes, Cyberdrifter. Yeah. So, sorry I'm not
sowing out yet cuz I haven't presented the content, but yes,
that is what this is all about. That is what this is all for.
It is purely to try to discredit Abby. Not even necessarily to
discredit her, but to try to intimidate her out of appearing
as a witness, unironically, because I believe what these guys
are saying is like, well, you know, when we were roommates, we
have things we could sue you for. Remember when you did this?
Remember when you did that? Maybe if you sue Destiny, maybe we'll
sue you.
I was like, "Okay, a valid reason." All right. Like,
don't agree. My media being shared. Don't find out until that's
a little that's a little bit of uh that's a little bit of a spoiler
for later in the conversation, but we'll get to there. This is
coercion, is it not? It certainly looks crazy to me. I don't
know how a judge interprets this. I'm just going to put together
this timeline for people a little bit, and then we'll uh we'll
we'll figure everything out. Okay. Did Abby live with them? Abby
used to live with uh Darius and Legacy.
Yes. Uh I believe they they've accused her of some pretty bad
things, but again, they can go to court over them, I guess, if
they want to. January,
we turned up just a titch more. Yep. You offered me to see Destiny
naked like 15
And videos of you and him. I rejected, but you were doing so
much. It just seems weird.
You can do whatever you want though. I don't think lawsuit will
help anything. If you feel like you want compensation, I just
DM
Steven. Uh, that seems weird, right? If you feel like you want
compensation, I just DM
Steven. That seems bizarre. Also, he's he's like, "Oh, you did
this thing, too." Which, by the way, Destiny, if she did that,
Destiny could sue her,
right? Destiny could just sue her. Anyway,
scenario for you, it seems.
Did you actually see them? Did I show them to you? Did I send
them to you? No. Was I an alcoholic piece of flaunting I had
it to you? Yes. He shared mine with a lot of people I didn't
know about until recently and more.
You weren't flaunting. You were going to show me until I literally
told you that. Sounds like if she did that, she wouldn't deserve
compensation. Hm. Uh well, one uh those things could be litigated,
I think, separately,
or you would show proof. But here, um I think both Darius and
her acknowledge she didn't actually share it. So, unfortunately,
this proves literally nothing. Uh except that maybe Abby was
like kind of a piece of and willing to violate people's consent,
too. But unfortunately, that doesn't make her testimony invalid,
and it doesn't make her claim against Destiny invalid. So,
Oh, whoops. I was You can't justify that action just because
you were drunk.
Well, thank you for stopping me. Yes, it was wrong of me. I'm
glad I was a
21-year-old on this one. I just want to I just want to point
out that
um Darius
literally took this girl who he obviously had kind of like a
spell over. Like she clearly even though he's super harmful,
he's harmed her significantly. I believe we've had multiple people
post the images of Darius choking her in the
Okay. Uh they've harmed each other, but she has like a thing
for him and she's clearly like under a spell. She's willing to
do whatever just to talk to him, right? And he's using that to
leak these DMs for Destiny's sake. Kind of putting a weird spotlight
on Destiny and absolving Abby of the crime he wants to commit
uh like uh what do you call it? Accuse her of at the same time.
Like it's actually it's almost
it's almost like poetic irony that he's like trying to help and
he's like Destiny by himself. It's
it's weird. It's it's it's almost poetic.
Absolutely. Damn. Well, but I didn't show you, bro. What? Or
anyone is the point. I don't even remember if you did. That's
not the point. What's the point? You were willing slash did show
this content to someone. you were without their permission. You're
mad at Steven for doing the same or joining a really [__]
about it. I just message Steven about it instead of tying yourself
to this. If you want money out of it, just message him. High
chances you get nothing out of this except wasting your time
and
resources. So, here's the thing. There's no
way that Destiny reached out to Darius about Abby, right? There's
no way that he would reach out to this
utter and go, "Hey, can you talk to Abby for me? I heard she's
like a witness or something. I heard she's like getting involved
in these lawsuits. Hey, Darius, could you like could you go figure
out what's going on?" There's no way he said this, right? There's
no way. Except
unfortunately in like the in the very short period of time before
this, it it appears there are references. Okay. Do we remember
when Darius and Zena went on Destiny's stream? Do we remember
this? Have we heard about this? Do we remember this? Where Darius
was crashing out about Zena saying she had a an STD. Do you remember
this? You tell. Now, this is on May 2nd. So, I think I think
this could be from this one from from this day. I think it is.
But speaking a totally different voice and speaking completely
different. Shut up. Shut up. 2023
vibes. Uh oh, that's where my life's currently stuck at. So,
we Okay, well, you're good with it. So, I'm debating if I So,
once I say it, it's dark. So, I'm just I'm giving it a second
to think. Okay. Wait, also this is nothing until you represent,
right? No, it's nothing to do with that. It's All right. What
do you got?
Huh? So, the day after these DMs are getting sent,
he says, "This is nothing to do with uh what I've been talking
to you about,
There's nothing. Hold on. There's nothing to do with that, right?
Whoa. Whoa. D. Wait, Darius. Hold on. There's nothing. Oh, don't
worry, Jacob. I've got that,
too. That's strange. That's very H. Now, I I'm not particularly
given to conspiracy, but it almost seems like there was some
foot. But we actually met Hold on, hold on, hold on. We had Wes
come on on the third. Oh, sorry. Yes, the 3rd of May. Okay. Published
on the 4th, but it was on the 3rd of May. Okay. That was weird.
He actually messaged me the other day. He was like, "What?" And
I was like, "What?" He's like, "Did Abby ever show you or tell
you that?" Hold on. What did he say? It was I was like, "Where
the coming from?" So now I'm just hearing this and it's starting
to make sense. He said, "Did Abby ever show or send you any videos
of us hooking up?" And I was like, "What? No. What the?" Now
I'm getting where it's coming from.
Wow. Very, very interesting. Now, it seems odd to me now. I don't
know. It seems It just seems odd to me that Destiny's been so
desperate. Not that. Okay, let me just tell you, okay, maybe
there's some world where this could be okay. I'm not totally
sure, but who knows? All
right. Um, maybe there's some world where where this could make
sense, but I don't understand why he'd be so desperate to reach
out personally instead of having his lawyers reach out. I don't
understand why he'd be this desperate. Unless Abby had seen some
or been sent some like I I just it doesn't make any sense to
me that you'd be this
sloppy cuz then lawyers know better. I Yeah, it's very strange
to me, right? It's very very very strange to me that he would
do this. I don't I actually don't understand. So, he had reached
out to both Wes and Darius. I believe he had talked to somebody
that was speculated to be a douche in the uh in the DG chat as
well. Where was Do I have these logs somewhere? Let me see. Destiny
Abby. So, there's some logs here where he's talking to somebody
here. Somebody's trying to ping him. Oh, wait. Legacy Rose, are
you the one who messaged me like a year ago talking about Abby?
How Abby was looking for ways to get money out of me way back
when? I'm trying to remember who the messaged me talking about
this. So, this is on Well, this is actually a day or two ago.
What? Oh, maybe this is a Wait, are there multiple logs of this?
I'm not totally sure. In any case, it's very strange. This whole
timeline is very strange. Okay, this is uh just recently. No,
no, no. There was another thing where he was talking to somebody,
but I can't remember the name. Anyway, if somebody wants to find
that screenshot for me, it' be interesting. There was another
point where he talked about how Abby was crazy because Abby had
reached out to him. I don't know if you guys remember this. I
believe this was on stream where he said, "Bro, this this girl's
like crazy." It might have been a DG chat, but it was like, "She
she messaged me out of nowhere. She messaged me out of nowhere."
It's like, oh, well, apparently Darius was saying if you message
Steven, you can work out a deal outside of the courts or something.
I wonder where Darius got that idea from, but who knows? Who
knows? Who knows? Who knows? You think this stuff is making Pixie's
case stronger? I think it has to be. No. Like, it might Well,
hold on. I don't know cuz I don't know if they'd ever be able
to subpoena stuff around this. It certainly seems concerning
to me, but obviously we have a lot of context that it would be
hard to deliver effectively to a judge. And I don't know. I'm
just not totally sure,
right? I'm actually just not sure. But it seems to me like there's
some weird going on here in terms of this timeline of Darius
reaching out and saying these things. I have no idea why Darius
leaks these logs. It looks so bad to leak these
logs. Lol. Letting manipulate you. At least Darius is self-aware.
Oh, dude. You So, let's just read this again. you were willing/
did show content to someone you were with without their permission.
So, she said she didn't. Darius says she didn't. So, he's like
trying to paint it in a different way. So, she's saying, "No,
no, no, I didn't." Which, by the way, is why Abby should never
have talked to her because Darius is trying to use this uh this
hold he has over her to get her to confess to things that she
may not have even done, right? Like, he's trying to drive her
in that direction. She should never have reached out to this
guy. This guy's like totally bad. Doesn't care about you. Doesn't
give a about you. Don't talk to Darius, okay? He will do whatever
he can to make sure Destiny is safe, including you over, so be
very careful. Uh, or joining a really lawsuit about it. I'd message
Steven about it instead of tying yourself to this. If you want
money out of it, just message him. High chances are you get nothing
out of this. He doesn't know any of this, by the
way. Or remember, because she was or is an alcoholic. I think
she's been sober for a while, but like she did have substance
abuse issues. I'm sure there's like bad things Abby has done.
I'm sure I think they go over some of them in this stream. I
don't really want to air them because I'm not going to participate
in that. But I do believe she's done some bad things. I just
don't think that like makes her I don't think that affects her
testimony, right? Just in the same way. Oh, hold on. This is
apparently the logs right here. Oh, this is apparently Nadouch
talking. Uh Destiny, I'm going to bed soon. If you want to talk
about a then just DM me. This is on May 4th.
Uh, Sushia. So, asking sushi, is it about a Destiny? Call me
really fast. I have something to say about you know who Destiny
talk to Nadouch. So, this is Nadouch coming in and saying like
Destiny, I'll leak you all the things about Abby. By the way,
Nadouch infamously schizotiple chatter who like is was literally
perma banned from Destiny's sub from everything. Like literally
gone from
everything. What does I've seen all the drives and all the tapes
of everyone else too mean? Uh, have we gotten to that log
yet? Uh, I think so. I can't tell if this is because she was
sent stuff. Darius claims it was because she was snooping through
his computer. I'm actually not sure. It's not clear from these
logs what actually happens here. So, we'll take a look. Well,
you can just message Destiny for money. Does that work? Okay.
Sorry. I don't even want the money. What he's doing has done
seems I've seen all the drives and the tapes of everyone else,
too. letting manipulate you is funny.
They pulled me in. You did the same thing. You literally showed
the same stuff. I get you've seen his stuff because you went
through. But she didn't do that. She literally claimed she didn't
do that. And Darius Darius literally said, The funny thing is
is he started this. It's so transparent what he's trying to do,
right? He's trying to get her to say she did so he can send those
logs to people. It's so
But she already said, Darius already said, "Well, I told you
not to send them to me." And she's like, "Yeah, thank you. Thank
you for making me not send them or whatever. And it's like, okay,
yeah, it's it's like literally nothing happened. And now he's
like now he realized that looks bad. So he's trying to get her
to something. I forget he literally took a picture of it off
his PC, which is again his business. I don't see how that's negative
that he has points of people he's been with.
What are you doing? You don't care about me. You don't care about
Kro. What am I doing? It's been months. Who are you protecting,
Steven? Why do you care? Really? Good response. I don't really
care. I just think it's a and you're adding yourself to more
autistic
again. It's his business. I don't see the negative that he is.
Those people he's been with. What are you doing? You don't care
about me or about Gavin. It's been months. Who are you protecting?
Why are you protecting Steven? Why do you care? Maybe you like
it at this point. I don't care. Good luck. This isn't Game of
Thrones. I'm not trying to protect anything. It's just annoying
that you're yet again coping and doing the tardy. It seems nobody
around you is able to put together the parallels. But it's okay.
Surely it'll be epic.
I really hope one day. Oh, uh, the Nadouche guy. Somebody sent
me a picture of Nadouche was Nadouch in Destiny before he was
banned. Nadouche infamously the the guy who set up Grace Thorp
to walk away from Darius and have Darius have a like actual autistic
rage meltdown. Cool, cool, cool, cool. These are these are, by
the way, these are Desty's primary shooters now, right? All of
the people he banned for being way too schizophrenic who stuck
around, these are Destiny's primary shooters. Okay, these are
the guys. These are his best guys now. The top guys. When you
can heal more, you realize the pain you can cause to others.
Yes, I think I'm further than you, which is ironic from what
I've seen on the sadness of your streams. But go ahead, get triggered
and block me again like always. I'll never have closure from
you. I don't need it. I'm on the right path. But I do hope you'll
realize the effect you can have on others sometime. I am too.
Trust.
If you realize that, you wouldn't send weirdass paragraphs to
people about how much better you're doing. Good chat.
Dude, what? I did that because I have money and I wanted to pay
back the most reasonable person on the lease, Danny. So, it sounds
like she did message Danny about paying extra damages and talk
about our relationship. I'm not even being stubborn. I'm not
totally sure where this goes from here. I can't remember. You're
being so open. You're being so mean, dude. If I hurt you that
bad, I'm very sorry. I've seen you call me fat, a wench, whatever.
It hurts still. I know you'll hate me that I've accepted it.
Except I'm moving on my life and I'm not dead like I tried to
be multiple times. I need serious help. You hurt me too much.
Still, you wouldn't give me the time a day. You never did other
than now suddenly in the Am I the Am I the only person who's
like feels like if I if I had somebody who like trusted me this
much? This would like
actually tear me up. Even if I didn't really like the person,
if they trusted me this much that they were going to tell me
like all these super private things, I feel like there's no way
I'd go on a public stream and air their logs out. Like like I
can't imagine how like that that cuts pieces of your soul off,
We did. Yeah, we did pass one of the do not leaks. Like that
actually shaves pieces of your soul. Like doing stuff like that,
like taking somebody's trust who trusts you this much that they'll
just take your word for it and then abusing that trust. That
is that
absolutely rend the soul. Okay. It's not good. Darius is too
loyal to Destiny to care about anyone else. Yeah, I know. I know.
I know. It's very sad. It's very sad stuff. The interest of Steven.
I know. It's Abby. She's a person. Yeah. I just I don't see the
world like that. I guess.
Yeah. I don't I'm a terrible
person. I know I'm a terrible person to you. Don't message me
unless you're interested or ever care about the pain you caused
me and how I retired. Aras is a soulless base. Thank you very
much for that message. I'm just recommending you probably don't
do the lawsuit thing. Seems pretty. And when you find a history
to say, you'll show me your photos of Stephen. It isn't a good
look.
What kind of legal argument is that? You said you'd send me something.
So, you know what? You suing him for for actually breaking the
law there. That's not a good look, actually. That's just not
a good look. Okay. Very bad look for you. No interest in talking
about our personal relationship as I don't believe you've changed,
nor do I care to ask it at the moment, as it was like 6 months
Are you saying you'd openly testify against me, or are you saying
you'd tell your stream that I'm not worried about a good look?
I'm saying exactly what the what I typed. What the are you interpreting,
bro? This isn't a detective game. This isn't Among Us.
What the do I care about? A good look, dude. What are you going
to tell your 300 botted viewers? Oh, damn. On your lame. Oh,
damn. Show. Come on now. What events do you have that will stand
in quite a lot that I would By the way, I will just say Darius
regularly has like 250 viewers and like three chatters, like
three active chatters. This is just a fact, unfortunately. Okay.
I didn't really want to pick at him over it, but yeah, when he
goes and works out, there's nobody chatting, but he has 250
right? Like, it's just very, very, very obvious and transparent
what's going on.
Acting will not look good. Is that a threat? I've not looked
good. I do not care. Thank you, though. You're dead,
What do you think? It'll give me money. What do you think? I
should just give up. I think you should eat lol.
Dude, do you have a minute to call? I'm a bad texter. Yeah, real.
Are you for real? Oh my god. I know you may not believe this,
but I'm generally out of the blue and confused. So, when you
unblock me, I did not immediately know what you were talking
about, and the shock of you doing this so casually threw me off.
For this, I am sorry. I have a job to work early in the morning.
Please do not tell me to eat or that you wish the worst for me.
I don't care what your opinion is of about me. I know you have
the empathy to understand with the history we have, and that
hurts me. You can tell me to eat all you want forever, but if
me doing this with the lawsuit hurts you enough in any capacity,
I'd reconsider. If you can be h dude, this is just brutal, right?
Like I feel like I feel like she badly wants Darius to just be
her friend to tell her it's okay. Like this is just sad to me.
Reasonable and try to talk to me cohesively and normally not.
Dude, what are you doing after how many months? I don't want
to hurt you and I was never planning on it. I promise. Please
don't do that. We can be adults. You reached out for a reason.
Don't back down from that. We can talk. Move on with life.
If you have an issue with what Steven did, I would suggest reaching
out to him. And if you feel obligated to something for it, I
just ask him. Seems way better and more reasonable than the lawsuit.
I don't think you do anything but garner negative attention to
yourself. And if you're trying to get away from this stuff, it
just seems kind of By the way, if you feel obligated to something,
that's not what the word obligated means. Darius doesn't know
even know. Not shocking that Darius would actually just not know
the definition of
obligation. That really just that's actually just a perfect character
fit, isn't it? Productive. If you didn't manage to if you didn't
attempt to do the same behaviors he did, I probably wouldn't
have a problem with you doing whatever, but it looks very backwards
when you would have done or have done the same thing if I gave
you consent.
Uh, hold on, hold on one second. Uh, I think Abby was/ is incredibly
vulnerable for multiple reasons. People may not see that or want
to see it, but it doesn't change the facts. This all just played
into Destiny's usual pattern of behavior. Yeah, I just don't
understand. Okay, like I I posted a message in um in my general
chat earlier, but I'll I'll read it cuz it just it's like literally
how I feel about this. Hold
on. Oh, one second. Let me find
it. This is like basically what I imagined Darius saying. Wow,
I can't believe this girl who apparently has zero self-esteem
and significant substance control issues did bad things. Anyway,
I'll accept her cleaning my room so she can suck my for the ninth
time. And then I'm totally done with her. I'm nexting her after
that. And then it was the 10th time. And then it was the 11th
time. It was like this like he's perfectly happy with having
somebody who's like sort of like broken and vulnerable around
him when it serves him. And then as soon as they're gone and
they they they're angry, it's like, "Oh, they're totally broken.
No, that don't listen to them. Don't trust them." No. What? Have
you heard that they're a do you not know that they're an insane?
And it's like, dude, how the you can't be somebody who who constantly
takes advantage of people like this and then go, wait, they're
saying something bad about me now. No, they're totally insane.
It just doesn't make any logical
There is, do you be using words like garner offream? Is that
real? Okay, good word. I appreciate that. Thanks. I'll reconsider.
But again, why do you care? You could have left me alone forever.
You know, you should have and wanted to, but just for Steven,
right? or because I'm stupid and you want me to realize this
and be right. I don't think this helps, Stephen. If anything,
it hurts someone messaging you about what you're doing. Why then?
Seems like I'm a goon. Cuz it's annoying to see you constantly
self-destructing, buddy.
Why does he want Danny? Yeah, I scrubbed your screen chat. Does
it have to do with me? Crazy odds. I just reached out to Danny
prior. No relation. No idea. I was just baiting.
Okay, thanks. Good to know. Well, I'm not doing this anymore
nearly as much as you seem to care since you reached out. I really
am doing better. I don't know why you assume based on this one
convo I haven't changed at all when I think we're basically done
with like the interesting parts of this. It's chill. I got involved
in this case in January. I was still drinking a bit. It's been
a long drawn out. I will point out that Darius also knew how
bad these logs looked like a couple weeks ago because he leaked
the later part of these logs on his stream a couple weeks ago.
Like two weeks ago, right? And now he's I don't understand why
he's leaking this part. It actually looks so pass.
You randomly assumed I was threatening you and tried to call
my stream honor
I don't care.
She called his stream botted. And that's the thing that sticks
in his mind, isn't it? He's like that. That was her really digging
the knife in. Okay. That's the thing that actually him off here.
Not any of the crimes, not any of the consent violations. You
call my stream botted. It's not
botted. God. Oh, uh, somebody just wanted to link this this funny
little log. So, apparently Destiny was totally out of this. Destiny
was like, "Listen, this is really weird, gross behavior." Rick,
I don't trust any of these people. There's a reason why in 2024
I was largely separated from basically all of them. Way too much
went back room log
sharing/dumping/coordinating/weird [__] And now we
have Destiny sitting in chat "Darius, get Darius to dump more
logs. Get Darius to leak more logs. Darius leak. Darius
leak." And then what happened the other day? Wasn't Darius like
getting self-conscious and he's like you you like didn't like
me before? You're like you like kind of just only started hanging
out with me now. And he's like Darius. Darius I with you. Darius.
He had to like he had to like actually wake Darius. Darius remember
my voice is the voice that programs you. Okay. Darius I with
you. I promise. Darius I with you. I promise I with you. Darius.
It's okay. Darius. I know you have I know you have all of the
dirt on me. I know you could totally like sink me in every way.
So I [__] with you, Darius. Okay, I keep telling
everybody I dumped all the toxic people and yet you keep coming
on my stream and having fights with Zena. Yeah, I get it. I none
of it makes sense. I with you, Darius. It's definitely not just
because you have all this dirt on me. I totally with you. Yeah.
Yeah, I did let other people like totally ban you from our canvasing
events. Yeah, I realized you were going to come and I we got
you like kind of nexted, but now that I have nobody else, I totally
with you, Darius. Okay, I love you, buddy. Anything else? Anything
else, buddy? If you don't believe this, I might have done the
same all to you guys, but I have lots of trauma. Yes, I keep
mentioning it. Please consider that having Please, please consider
having that patience. This gave me an anxiety tech. I have to
take a sand. That's a defensive mechanism aggression. I'm sorry
it happened. Uh, someone asked, "Who is Abby here in the Twitch
chat?" I missed this. Sorry about Sorry about that. The normie
215. Abby is Darius's former roommate. Thankfully, Destiny leaked
who Abby was. So, we we
All right.
Darius was banned from attending events. Darius was supposed
to come to the event. I believe they set up a chaperone for him.
I said Erdite, but I actually don't know. They set up a chaperone
for him and then basically people were like, "You know what?
Actually, we don't want you at this event. You shouldn't come
to this event." And he didn't get to go. They kicked him out
and I took his side. I said, "That's up of you guys. I said that's
up. You guys banned Darius when you actually set up him going.
You got his hopes up and now you banned him. That's actually
super Destiny. Do you remember when uh the Molina was going down
and you Darius, sorry, you Destiny, you totally sunk D. You didn't
take Darius's side at all. Even though you did believe him. You
knew he was telling the truth in a bunch of those cases. Okay.
Didn't take his side at all. You didn't take his side whatsoever.
And you just ban him. You you let him be abused by your by your
community for like months and you just ban him from your events.
That's up, dude. Why would you take a side? He was obviously
going to be creepy there at the minimum. Yeah, but there's like
three women that would be there in the first place, so there's
just not really that much risk. When there's like 900 guys and
three women, he just there's too many eyes on
him. And Nick was supposed to be with him. So, I'm I'm sure Nick
would have kept him from being a total creep. Do your thing.
I'm happy for your stream or whatever. was an insult. Shouldn't
have. Please don't make me your content anymore. I've seriously
been through enough of that. I really hope that some part of
you doesn't hate me, can understand how badly this has affected
me. And I really hope that there's a reasonable part of you can
still under you think Darius feels like any amount of guilt here
whatsoever for like like when they read messages like this. Does
anybody not like feel this at all? Like like apparently that
there's a bunch of people viewing this stream. Do they not see
that this is like just like you're I'm sorry, but you you are
actually like you're hurting your soul. Like you you are actually
cutting pieces off of it, doing like horrible things to other
people. I hope I hope some of them realize this. You would hope,
but who knows? Understand? Everything I did and every everyone
I hurt was because I could not handle my pain and I was an
addict. Oh my god. Okay, there's more. I've accepted I'll never
be forgiven by you or Hayden. I'm really okay living with that
and one day I won't sad. I don't expect you to understand or
ever forgive me at all. I'm still in the process of forgiving
myself. You should too. I don't know what to do now. So, I'm
ser to my boy Gavin. Now I couldn't give a You realize she lives
with Gavin right now, right? Baked till crisp. Like her and Gavin
are
dating. Do you not realize that or they ran away together?
What do you what do you what I'm seriously after you said I got
involved at first to help the others involved. I did not think
the possibility to message him myself. What do you think would
happen? I'm scared. I'm at work. I can't explain more now. Maybe
later. Just have a good day.
I don't think you need to be scared. Steven is a Just message
him. Okay. Okay. Well, in short, can't talk now. My lawyers want
to sign want me to sign a couple final documents today and I
have to print them after work and get them in by midnight. Well,
think about it. It's been a long process. I'm reconsidering.
Don't talk to him or tell him that he's asking or fishing about
me. All right, but I probably don't talk to him or tell him that
he is asking or fishing about
What? My lawyers want me to sign a couple final documents today
and I have to print them after work and get them in by midnight.
dude after work and sorry I was uh reading chat and I didn't
see uh I didn't see this but yeah I don't think you need to be
scared if Steven is a just message him he's literally leveraging
every part of his personal relationship to try to get her to
stop right to try to get her to um to stop joining this lawsuit
get them in by midnight think about it it's been a long process
I'm reconsidering don't talk to him or tell him that he's asking
or fishing about me all right but I'd probably just message him
before you finalize anything
yeah that's what I plan to It's a bit hard to reach out after
so many months and be like, "Hey, I'm involved." So, you know,
this might get Should I just cut you the slack and move on? I
have to think about this. Seriously, I've made it very far legally.
So,
uh, no. Just tell him your issue and ask him what you feel like
you're owed so you feel like you can handle it out of court,
lol. Instead of causing a PR nightmare for everyone
Okay. Thanks for that advice, Darius. I'm shocked you care to
give it. Oh my god, bro. I wouldn't be I wouldn't be a PR nightmare
for me. For him only, possibly you.
Cope him. It'd be easy content for me. So, not really.
But you're right. I can and have thought plenty times to abandon
this and move on with my life. My lawyers call every week and
rope me back in. Please just don't right now, bro. Not until
I find out. By the way, my lawyers My lawyers quote unquote all
my lawyers. Pixie lawyers. only she does is like personally
do these guys not understand that she is like filing a lawsuit
against Destiny uh for the same thing or Destiny sharing the
pictures in the the same way he did video in the same way that
he did or maybe it's just media I can't remember I can't remember
what it said in the in the affidavit but like it's the exact
same thing exact same statute
yeah anyway okay that's the only PR that Abby knows that yeah
that's just typed in chat this combo was made first and they
filed
wouldn't be a PR night for mayor for me. Only possibly uh for
me only him possibly you. Wait a second. Yeah. Uh Aby's literally
saying this in by midnight. She's lally talking the night before.
Hey, she's reconsidering the day
Insane, dude.
Uh probably annoying for him, but yeah. I mean, if you want to
do that to him. I I love how
not to be rude, but poor people, how they interact with like
like lawsuits and stuff like that. I I like this. It's very funny.
Probably annoying for him. But yeah, I mean, if you want to do
that to him, go ahead. But if you want to gain anything from
this, messaging him would be better. The lawsuit seems pretty
bunk. True. I've known for like two months, so I'm chill. What?
Based on what? I just I don't even know. I don't think these
guys understand what they're talking about
I usually don't.
You don't know a lot, man. No offense. Unless I don't know. Maybe
my been leaked. Talk later. Maybe I could tell you. I'm got to
work. Just realize you don't know the full extent or details
at all. I didn't even until recently, and I'm still learning.
Thank you. I don't want to do anything to anyone anymore. Please,
believe me, I was only attempting to help Pixie and others leaked.
And yes, my been leaked a lot, too. I didn't know about Lucky.
Not public. It's just been a long drawn out process these months.
I've been over it and I want it resolved too. It's going to be
drawn out even long.
it's I all I can really think is if the lawsuit's so bunk, why
is Destiny risking something by trying to reach out to people
to get information about one of the people accusing him? If it's
just if Pixie's lawsuit has no legs, if Aby's lawsuit would have
no legs, why is he risking this in any way? Are you risking reaching
out to total?
Uh, one second. I just had to send a message really quickly.
You don't know a lot, man. No offense. Unless I don't know, maybe
my been leaked. Talk later. Maybe I could tell you. I'm got to
work. Just realize you don't know the full extent or details
at all. I didn't even until recently, and I'm still learning.
Thank you. I don't want to do anything to anyone anymore. Please,
believe me, I was only attempting to help Pixie and others leaked.
And yes, my been leaked a lot, too. I didn't know about Lucky,
not public. It's just been a long drawn out process these months.
I've been over it and I want it resolved, too. It's going to
be drawn out even longer as well. Like I said, just DM him and
tell him I'm the issue.
Okay, I will. Thanks, man. You don't think he'll attack me or
tell me to off? I thought the legal way was more mature, professional.
Oh, man. I don't know if you think he won't be hostile.
Whatever. That's not your place to tell me. Uh you
whatever that means. I don't know. You want me to have a good
day? Uh it's going to be long drawn out even longer. I said,
like I said, just DM him and tell him the issue,
bro. Okay. I'm not familiar to with the case, but if Darius is
part of the case, it's going to be a [__] show. Darius
is not part of the case. But if you were here a little bit earlier
than normie, we showed two clips where Destiny was reaching out
to people like Darius and Wes, by the way, and asking for information
on Abby. And for some reason, Darius, after being reached out
to decides to go over to Abby and start messaging her at saying
like, "Just message Destiny about this. If you want some money,
just message Destiny,
right?" Like I Yeah, not yet. Yeah. I basically that's what it
is. Like this this looks so [__] bad.
highly doubt he will.
Okay, I'll be reasonable and try that lawyers have advised against
it. I don't want him to turn around and use it against me in
court and [__] with me if I do talk to him. Like,
surely my lawyers would me, but if I settle with it, if I settle
it with him and avoid everything else and move on, I will. And
hopefully Pixie and everyone else will be okay.
Yeah, let me know how it goes.
Stay as professional as I can be. I I don't want to get for this
actually cuz it gets like it gets bad. She like talks a lot.
So like if you like have like help you but she talked a lot and
just kind of one side of response.
Apparently my lord would kill me but if I can settle it with
him and avoid everything else and move on I will. I think this
is like if you message somebody, there's no way. I I don't believe
that Destiny would be enough to message Darius and say, "Hey,
like point her in this direction." There's no possible way. It's
actually like it's in my mind it's like impossible, but he could
have said like talk to Abby. Yeah. Oh my god. I just It's so
so dumb. I don't know why you would leak anything that would
push people in this direction to think that this could happen.
But like, yeah, now now she's been convinced. And then I believe
after this, Destiny says something like, "Oh, she messaged me."
And she's like, "Uh, she's totally crazy. I have no idea why
she would message me instead of lawyers. I don't even know if
she's allowed to do
No, I'm chilling. I'm a lock in. I got it. Just got to clear
my throat here. I'm looking at a big old do not leak this. So,
Oh, boy.
state as professional as I can be. I don't want to get for this.
You can seriously turn around and me with this. But yeah, kind
of glad you reached out. I was contemplating further. Anyway,
by the way, I wasn't going to leak this. Only reason. Okay. Uh
the only reason he's leaking it is remember remember Oh, hold
on. The only reason he's leaking it is
this. Ivory, tell him to leak more logs. Right. This is why he's
leaking it. So he's like, "Oh, I totally wasn't gonna leak this,
but he leaked Abby was trying to blackmail him with a lawsuit.
Ivory, tell him to leak more logs. FS. That's why he's leaking
it." Because Destiny asked him to leak
it. Destiny, the person who is in the lawsuit, the person who
is being sued by Abby and Pixie, or I don't know about Abby yet.
I don't know if there's a formal complaint yet, but like that's
who asked him to leak more logs and then he did.
There is death idiot. Okay, first off, I didn't anybody. I'm
as you see, but okay, I'll be honest. My messages here aren't
the best. But I honestly have I'm very hostile to this person
cuz I'm very mad at them. But two, about it. Two, I was not going
to leak any of this and I was going to not I was going to leave
it alone. But then she said she's going to she's going to talk
to her lawyers about me and put me in jail. I was like, this
dude, she said she's going to have a domestic assault charges
on me. I'm like, okay, you I don't I don't care about your autonomy
in any way, shape, or form when you're trying to you're trying
to get me to go. You're trying to put assault charges on me from
something from eight months ago. Uh, and they weren't even It
wasn't even assault. It was It wasn't even assault. Okay, go.
All right. Uh, go on.
Kind of glad you reached out. I was contemplating not going further
anyways. So, thanks. We'll see if he's mean. I was contemplating
on not going further. This is again she she This is at 2 2 p.m.
She uh she was in at midnight on the 2nd. So, what? Okay, never
mind.
In case of an investigation by any federal entities or similar,
I do not have any involvement with this group or people in it.
I do not know why I'm here, probably added by a third party.
I do not support any actions by the members of this group. Do
not leak this. Thank you, Darius. Looked up my name on Russell
search after work. Saw stuff relating to your argument. I wanted
to clarify. I tested as recently as December. I am completely
clean and have been my whole life and will show you results if
you need. I promise you I'm not involved. Good luck with this
awful thing to go through. I had a scare for Abby. It's hard
to understand how a person you might care about in some way sees
you as less than trash basically to have leaked all this. Bit
of a Yeah, exactly. But like now I literally don't feel bad about
Darius getting his DMs leaked from Zena. Like when Zena leaks
all of his DMs going totally insane mode talking about himself
with her. I don't feel bad about reading any of those. I don't
feel I I didn't really already but like he actually deserves
it. Like I I actually it felt a little bad but he actually deserves
it, right? He absolutely deserves it.
There's no part of him that is a good person. Um I I pray he
can get away from Destiny at some point and try to be his own
human being here with Hayden and it turned out to be a UTI. Dude,
seriously, dude. Are you lied or not? I need to talk. What are
you doing?
About what?
I know you're hurting deep. I know you've been hurting since
way before I ever met you. Since Sushi, this is written with
AI. What the [__] M dash.
Really? Okay. since sushia and maybe even way before that. But
you've got to break this loop. I don't follow you, but I know
you're trying food for people that have
Oh, the current state of the Destiny orbit. Okay. These are Destiny's
primary shooters. Okay. Why is he dressed like the fellow fellow
kids
meme? Did you see Desi retweeted Tom today? There's a Destiny
retweet on Tom Foolery where Tom Fer is like Dean was in my chat
begging me to come on my stream. I I was just like, "Dude, you
didn't let Dean on your stream. You have you have like 6,000
followers on Tik Tok," which is a lot or wait, hold on. How How
many does he have? Tom Fery Tik Tok. Uh Tik Tok.com/tomfery show.
Is it 6,000? It's 841. Sorry, it was almost 6,000 likes. He's
got 841 viewers followers. Why would he not let Dean on his stream?
Why would you not pull Dean on your stream and like have the
chance of blowing up? What
insane? Anyway, sorry. I'll let this uh I'll let this read. I
need to use the bathroom really quickly. I'll be right
About what?
I know you're hurting deep. I know you've been hurting since
way before I ever met you. Since Sushi, this is written with
AI. What the dashing? Really?
Okay. since Sushia, maybe even way before that. But you've got
to break this loop. I don't follow you, but I know you're trying
to for people that have that sentence wasn't written with AI.
Okay, I know it's not your fault and I do feel sorry for you.
The people who understand you best, who really get this this
is AI. I'm I'm telling you, by the way, who really get the cycle
of pain that comes with love, no, it's not something you just
break out of overnight. When love When you love someone as broken
and as much pain as Zena, and all you want to do is help, but
you just can't. You don't really have a choice to leave for your
own health and happiness and for everyone who else been affected.
Nanny's suffering really bad today. She's a friend I met at the
very end. She means a lot to me now. It me to see her going through
similar stuff to what I went through and others worse. Uh especially
knowing she doesn't deserve it. She's so ignorant of this man.
I'll do nothing but protect her from as much as I can. But I
don't know. Uh real quick, she tries I I so mad that she I even
told Nani I was like I don't know why you ever talked to this
girl. She started talking to Nani because she started like trying
to Abby thinks she dealt with the same thing that Nani had to
deal
with again just like somebody who's hurting and he's just like
totally on them because Destiny on a whim was like you should
leak more. Oh my god.
Okay, sorry I didn't get water, but I need to because Zena is
crashing out and trying to like ruin Nani's life or whatever,
which is the only similar comparison they have. Abby, I never
had intention to date. I was never going to date. I was never
talked about a relationship with. Uh we kind of just like had
like a thing where we like talked at the start and we kind of
were like flirty, flirtatious, like romantic, semi-romantic or
whatever. Uh, and then like after like a little after like I
left uh Rhode Island, I there's literally a log of me saying
like, "Hey, just, you know, you're being a little bit too much.
Uh, and I'm not going to do I'm not going to pursue a relationship
with you because I think you're way too clingy and I think you're
way too like uh like codependent. I mean, I don't want I don't
want to I don't want I'm not going to I I can if I go through
the logs, I can pull up that exact message." Uh, with Donnie,
I That makes this all okay, by the way. Okay, that makes this
all okay. Uh, you can leak all of this because you didn't want
to date this girl long term. That makes this all cool. That makes
this all awesome.
Very much was considering a relationship with her. We were talking
um about one at one point. Uh, and it was like someone that was
trying to like do the thing. The only tie she has with Nani is
just as Cena.
All right.
Even if you block me or say horrible things about me, I'll always
care too. And I know and understand now. I didn't have the patience
before, but I get it. Protect Nani. Keep doing so. Please. I'm
encouraging her to change her number. I'll help if I have to.
I know how bad that hurts. Just please think about how bad it's
hurting. Even if Zena's just being skitso. We know she's nuts.
I am, too. So are you. But she needs serious help. And she can't
be hurting people around you. I'm not your chatter. Do what you
want with your life. I'm not your fan. I'll always care about
you and so will Gavin, but I'd hate to see you destroy yourself
more. Same you said to me, that's why I care. Understandable.
I think you have to pay us for damages as Denny doesn't get hit
with it. 1,000 or
Wait, did she delete messages?
This is not interesting. Yeah, well, this part isn't interesting.
Obviously, the stuff from the beginning is very interesting.
I don't care about them litigating like damages and from their
So, I just can't believe I don't know why in my head I'm like,
Darius, how can you be so like the primary part of this when
you've talked to Destiny on stream? You make it seem like, hey,
you had a secret conversation. We know Destiny had an off-stream
conversation with Wes for the first time in forever asking for
updates about Abby,
right? Like, that makes all of this look
suspect. I think you're just you're too concerned and overthinking
too much. Oh, in what way, Adam 66? Possibly, but I don't know
what we're talking about there. I'm just saying this looks suspicious.
I thought this was like very funny. Also, just like basically
setting up something. So, one, you know that uh there on Abby,
somebody who is apparently going to be suing you, is a already
a sealed witness in your case. The person you said was this person,
right? Or you were the first one, Destiny, to say this is Darius's
roommate. Okay. And then not only that, you're sitting in your
chat and commenting on this stream and driving traffic to it.
You're like driving your audience to this
stream. I also think you're talking about this too much. Just
reach out to Destiny if you feel obligated to
something. From your understanding of the lawsuit, could Pixie's
lawyers ask for Destiny/ Darius's communications in Discovery
because of the stream, or is it too late for that? I don't believe
it's too late. No, I don't think Discovery's even ended.
I think they're still in
discovery. By the way, I don't think we get all the discovery
documents. I think they request things back and forth, right?
Like in terms of they they have conference and they request things
back and forth. I think it's only if they have a dispute like
we shouldn't have to give you this, then they will produce additional
documents, right? Or then then they'll do something through the
court. Yeah. So, like they're they're literally in discovery
right now as far as I know. So, I don't see how this could possibly
be too late.
Anyway, all right. I think that is about it for this. I don't
think I had anything else here. There is there are logs of Destiny
talking about how Abby was like crazy for messaging him and he
had no idea why she was messaging him, right? They're trying
to first coers this girl into just dropping her herit to like
remain friends with them. And then when that doesn't work, they're
going to start humiliating and leaking things about her, right?
That's that's more what I'm talking about. They're not trying
to win the case in in a legal sense. They're trying to make her
drop out and go into hiding is what they want to do,
right? Yeah. Nothing about the affidavit changes at all.
Protective/confidentiality. I don't have uh I can't buy documents
on Pacers, so I don't know what that is. Okay. All right. I think
that's it. Again, I was looking for the one p I can't remember
if it was in logs or if it was on a stream where Destie talked
about Abby reaching out to him. It was like, this is this is
crazy. I don't even know if she's allowed to do that without
her lawyers being the ones to do it. And uh and it turns out
that Darius is the one encouraging her repeatedly, like actually
manipulating her into messaging Destiny. That looks
bad. Real quick, somebody sent it to me. Okay. Or at least something
close to
Um I I'm about to find it. Hold on. Makes more sense now. Oh
my god, I just had a brain blast. Some people have been communicating
with me privately that um should I actually I don't give a [__]
now. They shouldn't be talking to me privately and you So this
is where after after Darius bered Abby repeatedly to contact
Destiny privately after Destiny reached out to Darius. Okay,
this is the 10th of May. It's probably either from the 10th or
the 9th. Destiny decided to go on stream and start maligning
somebody for contacting him privately.
Do you realize that it's like his guy who is pushing this person
who's like trying to like actually threaten this person like,
"Hey, you blackmail me. Hey, you you did this crime, too. Hey,
hey, you can't do this. It'll be a it would be a nightmare for
you. Should be communicating only through your lawyer." And the
fact that they've been communicating with me privately seems
to imply to me that there is a heavy amount of pressure with
opposing council to elicit what I would say are obviously false
statements in order to keep this case alive. And I think that
is I think I think I look forward to showing up of the next court
filing. It feels to me like opposing council is in over their
heads. Don't work in this area of law at all. This Joan Peters
person is a something kind of some kind of immigration lawyer
from Puerto Rico. And this other guy I guess is just uh I don't
even know what law he does for everything. Maybe car accidents.
I don't know. Um but they're in Man, he had such a different
energy when they applied for this. Way over their head. Uh there's
way too much involved here. They don't know basic rules of of
civil procedure, which I understand is civil probably is your
hardest law school class. I don't know, maybe go back and and
and take a refresher on it. Um, and I think they're at a point
now to where I I legitimately it feels like it feels like what
they're doing is they are grabbing random people to perure themselves,
but they're telling the people, "We'll keep your identity anonymous
so everything will be okay." Because some of these people have
expressed a great deal of the level of uh insane. The level of
insane conspiratorial thinking here is
ridiculous. I don't So, by the way, we now know that Darius would
have leaked these DMs to Destiny and then Destiny would have
uh read them and this was like his reading of those DMs we saw
earlier tonight, right?
None of this is proven out by the DMs that she got at all. It's
just total conjecture, right?
It's like you can just see how he's like spinning the lies in
real time. Yeah. Uni. I don't know if he knows this, but the
motions are you make a motion and that is unilateral and then
they get to respond and then the judge will like actually I don't
know make a decision. But like how do you how do you just speak
a sentence unilaterally like that? No, that's the actually the
first step in communication. You say something then I say something
and then we come to an understanding over time. Oh my god. as
the full unredactive substantive content of the Oh, sure, sure,
sure. Anyway, we don't need to go through more of this, but I
just thought it was funny that he um that this is how he represented
this, right? We've now seen all the DMs that he's referring to.
And we now know that he just spun this conspiracy out of like
literally
Bonus meme. Brittany Simon really hates Not So Ariodite. Okay.
Uh let's see. We got Britney on Not So Arerodite. Let's check
it out. an actual belief that she thinks she is literally better
than other women and other women suck, but she's one of the good
ones. So much as she believes that she could be the woman to
make misogynists think maybe women aren't that bad. Kyla, I think
in this bubble, I think she thinks people need her, which is
why she has to do it. I think the idea is like people need you
so they don't get radicalized. You are on the left. All you can
do is prove your purity or be kicked out, right? And
so, do you get what I'm saying? This is why I can't engage with
Kyla. What? And I know FD is trying to make a bridge with Kyla,
but I think that's a mistake, too. I think making a bridge with
Kyla is the same as trying to make a bridge with Kidology. It's
just not worth. As much as I dislike Erdite, she is far less
evil when it comes to Britney. What did Britney do that was evil?
She said really inappropriate things about Destiny's kid. Other
than that, I actually don't know.
I legitimately don't know what she did that was evil. She kind
of sucks. She kind of runs a cult. I guess maybe you could say
it's evil depending on how cognizant you think she is of those
I think she I think she's kind of Why are we watching Aiden?
Oh, true. Who's got the picture, bro? Somebody leaked me the
Britney only faked lupus once. Wait, Britney faked lupus? She
didn't have
lupus. That's too bad.
think selling your only fans to your cult members is pretty bad.
I think the pseudootherapy plus uh only fan stuff, yes, is uniquely
taking advantage of the uniquely vulnerable. But I'm just saying
in terms of like the content, in terms of what she does, if you
I guess aren't in that pipeline, maybe we could say that pipeline's
pretty bad, too. But if you're if you're not in that pipeline
from my perspective, like Britney's pretty nonharmful. Like her
group doesn't like harass other people from what I can see, right?
That is 100% evil. You can say it that way. I think I
I'm having to readjust because I feel like I attacked her when
like her comments publicly her comments publicly don't make her
evil. It might be that her business model is evil. It's possible.
Okay. I've had to deal with chat a lot in the last minute. I'm
going to listen again cuz I want to hear the immediate criticism
she makes. I don't know that Kyla internalizes an actual belief
that she thinks she is literally better than other women and
other women suck but she's one of the good ones so much as she
believes that she could be the woman to make I do not believe
that like in terms of lesser evil that Britney is the that either
of them is the lesser evil. I think misogynists think maybe women
aren't that bad. Kyla I think in this bubble I think she thinks
people need her which is why she has to do it. I think the idea
is like people need you so they don't get radicalized. You are
on the left. All you can do is prove your purity or be kicked
out. Right? And
so do you get what I'm saying? This is why I can't engage with
I don't understand the purity testing that like the way we defeat
purity testing is purity testing, right? If you're on the left,
the only thing you could do is be purity tested or get kicked
out. Show your pure or get kicked out. Also, Hassan is out. Vant
is not pure. Kyla, what? And I know FD is trying to make a bridge
with Kyla, but I think that's a mistake, too. I think making
a bridge with Kyla is the same as trying to make a bridge with
Kidology. It's just not worth it for progressive like goals.
But I would say that's because they aren't deconstructing enough.
I don't know where build this peasants copper so Gidra can live
on.
well, thank God we're we're making that money. And I don't know
where Kyla will be, but to me, they're probably not going to
be very left. No, Kyla can't sit with us. She picked Destiny
over Hassan. She should have just picked neither of them cuz
they're both men and useless. Then where's my bridges episode?
Wow. Miss Andre W. Notice that Kyla never asked me to come on
bridges even though we were quote friendly. Notice that Kyla
never reached out to me. Notice Kyla never wanted to build the
bridge with me. Right. What makes it look like there are so many
angry men is the fact that a lot
unfortunately you decided against Destiny. And that's realistically
Kyla's only moral compass. Okay. Are you with Destiny or against
him? Okay. Would you talk to Destiny someday or not? If no, you
are unironically evil. a lot of men, including Kyla, keeping
friends with the men who are predatory and who are ultimately
like upholding the patriarchy in a bad way. And there's a reason
Myin and Destiny still got each other's back and Kyla is is still
has Steven's
back. You know what I mean? So, I don't think it's like ah, she's
kind of spitting though, like a little bit. Like I listen, I
don't necessarily want to agree with Britney wholeheartedly,
okay? But god
damn, because Kyla is a Destiny or a Myin, but I think Kyla makes
it look like there's more of him. And that's the thing is like
Kyla asked when it was all happening, she asked um Turkey to
Tom, am I supposed to abandon my friend? That's why somebody
like Kyla gets to come on and say, "I'm actually the college
graduate. I'm actually the girl who's not an OF model. Look at
me. I do podcasts with FD Signifier and CJ the X. Like I'm not
like these other girls. Yeah. You know, um Kyla and I had a good
run together. We had some good collaborations. I sent her a letter
just saying like your constant supportive Steven after everything
he's done. It's just like too much and I need to go in a separate
direction. I wish her the best and I wish Kyla the best as well.
I just wish she wasn't spending it with all these really gross
men. And I do think that Kyla does, from my understanding of
her work, desire to work with boys, does desire to help men,
and it can kind of appear like a pickme a little bit with Kyla.
But I think what Kyla is doing um is genuinely coming from a
compassionate place. I think that Kyla wants to help men. The
dilemma is that these men don't care about her, don't care about
her, won't uplift her, and just don't give a about her opinion.
But I can't give Kyla her flowers. Even though it it's uncomfortable,
you know, not trying to take anything away from anybody. Kyla,
what are you doing, Kyla? But she's doing it because and I have
to By the way, this is edited together. I have no idea how it's
edited if it's edited together. Well, this I think she might
be a part of it. I'm just I'm sorry. I'm losing track of like
the sentences at places where like it's not the same. Not trying
to take anything away from anybody. Kyla
like that. I don't know where that cut is going to necessarily.
What are you doing, Kyla? But I would just say for Riyle, I like
videos like this, but I know you edit them together quickly.
I think there should be some more obvious thing in the transition
that like lets it uh if you'd add auto transitions of some kind.
She's doing it because, and I have to accept this, I think she
might be a part of it. As much as I want to believe Kyla is genuine
and maybe she's just naive, she is with Steven. And Steven is
the epitome of playing the role.
Dude, Britney is like actually so so base right now. Yes, I believe
Kyle as well where she was like, I'm just really lost and I'm
following my principles. And like at some point I'm like, okay,
this doesn't make any sense anymore. Like you're somebody who
can't apply like basic like some basic logic. You're you're the
person who worked in addictions counseling, okay? Who's not willing
to force an addict to bottom tip $3. Please unban I am poor.
I live in third row country. Sorry, Moonray Murray. If you guys
come in and do that right after I say it, you you actually just
each forever until you've paid the 20. You might have to do $3
installments for a couple months. Okay. But unfortunately now
you you've turned me into the parent. I gave you the rules and
I didn't even want to enforce them. I didn't want to ban you,
but you like actually asked me to ban you. Please ban me and
make me owe you $20. You asked me for that. I don't know why
you asked me for that. I don't I actually didn't want to. But
unfortunately, I I gave the rules and then you had to go against
the rules. So now I had to do what I said I would do. It sucks.
I wish we weren't
He is cosplaying as a liberal or as a as a progressive, right?
This one time she told me I'm like her she I remind her of her
dad and her dad has autism and I was like well I have autism.
Is Kyla neurode divergent? Kyla's ner divergent ADHD so that
could play a role. Oh is she ADHD? Because I've been wondering
that like is Kyla's neur divergence playing a role in her naivity.
Britney been throwing up a lot of W's here so far. Britney please
do not do not excuse this because of ADHD. Okay. Whoa. Is she
on Bance? Is that why she can't hold this person accountable
for any of their actions? Is that what's Oh, I see. I don't think
she'd actually see. And also her desire to sort of help people
she sees who are struggling, especially Destiny. Cuz Destiny
is the little boy she wants to save. The question is why does
she want to save little boys? Yes. Like that's the thing. It's
like Destiny.
Oh my god. Britney Simon out here just absolutely dunking. Okay.
What
the? She's asking all the right questions. I have a feeling she
won't have quite the inflammatory but correct
Kyla is trying to save.
I wonder if there could have been some event in when Destiny
was younger that might have arrested his development and could
make him an adult little boy for Kyla to save. Huh? But Kyla
because she wants to save boys. Chad says, "I think what Kyla
is saying is too nebulous and vague to really gauge what her
relationship dynamic with Nick is." Well, I have seen her relationship
conversations with Nick, as has my Discord, cuz we've talked
about them. And I do think Kyla thinks she's married to some
hyper masculine man when in my bubble, he's not.
I'll be real. I was I watched some of this before and I watched
and I felt bad for going in on Britney like on behalf of Destiny
before, so I was giving her a little too much charity. Yeah,
the business model is still the business model still really now
that I'm thinking about it. But anyway, go back to we'll go back
to her
nebulous vague relationship dynamic with Nick. Well, I have seen
her relationship conversations with Nick as
my Kyla thinks she's married to some hyper masculine man when
in my bubble he's not. So, I think Kyla is uh in a different
bubble than me. When she talks about Nick being this like very
masculine presenting man, I'm like, "In what bubble?"
Sips tea. In what bubble? sips tea.
In what bubble? You know what I mean? Like in what bubble? So
like we obviously have differences without looks, too. I also
think Kyla's coping a lot about her life. She also said she fights
a lot and I don't know what that means in a marriage. Like I
don't know. I don't trust people who say they fight in their
marriages. Like I don't know what that means. Oh. So when Kyla
says like, "Oh yeah, like fighting has made our marriage stronger."
I don't know what that is. I don't know what you talk
I don't know what you talking about, Sipsy. I don't know what
that is. I'm not sure about that. Sips tea. Why does she do this
thing though? You notice Kyla does this thing? Is this a submissive
action where she tries to like head tilt and is she looking cute?
I don't
get, you know, I'll be honest. Before she had her fall out with
Destiny and I was like kind of I didn't mind Britney Simon content
sometimes. Okay. Sometimes the content's pretty funny. This is
like way overreading, but I love it. I love watching just people
overread like this. Okay. Said she fights a lot. Like I don't
know what that means. So when Kyla says like, "Oh yeah, like
fighting has made our marriage stronger." I don't know what that
is. I don't know what you
about. Why did she do this thing though? Oh, but did she do it
there? I didn't see her do it.
Oh, this thing though. You notice Kyla does this thing. Is this
a sub? Yeah, that's because she's trying to adjust her back because
it hurts because she's carrying a lot of weight that she wasn't
carrying, you know, a year and a half ago. Missive action where
she tries to like head tilt and is she looking cute?
Sorry, that was a boob job joke, not a getting fat joke. I don't
get what she she does that a lot. I wonder if it's the microphone.
Is she trying to see him over the microphone? No, that was a
that was a boob job joke, not a not a not anything else.
It's both. Well, it might have been both, but intentionally just
the just the boob job joke. Okay, that was all it was intentionally.
Okay.